so our first ever villager hunt now we
have identified a top ten my son and I
my six-year-old son you guys know
regulars of the stream know I talk about
him all the time he's a big animal
crossing' fanny
he's been playing at a ton so he doesn't
care about tier lists and all this stuff
on line of people like saying this is
the top tier villager I mean really it's
all just kind of memes anyway right
here's his top three his top three
octavian ribbit frog that looks like a
robot I don't know why Ribbit's not
higher on a lot tearless because I
thought ribbit looked pretty awesome too
and Drago who's an alligator that's his
top three my top three are ketchup a
little duck uh bow it was a deer and
then Ramon's just because everybody goes
crazy for Raymond but basically we had
someone move out so Lionel moved out so
we've got his Diana sick again she was
just sick dude wait what the heck
if only I'd noticed sooner and watered
them I can't help but feel this is my
fault at least a little bit what so
we're gonna talk to Orville here so you
can go ahead and get the plane fired up
and basically when you find the one that
you want you keep talking to them and
get them to move to your Island and so
there's a lot of these on YouTube and on
people to do this on Twitch sometimes
this could go on for hours on end for
hours on end and you never find the one
you want you reckon maybe use all your
nook miles tickets using up a miles
ticket I think at like 12 right now left
to buy some more a little bit later so
what I'm gonna do I've got like I had a
hundred thousand nuke miles points to
you so we could we could buy a ton of
milk miles ticket says if we needed to I
think maybe fifty might be a good start
so if we find Octavian or ketchup from
the get-go I'm done you know we'll get
them and that'll be it at a 391 though
chances are we're not gonna find them
right away our whole top so our top our
full top ten I didn't even tell you the
full top ten so Octavian ketchup bow
rain
ribbit Drago stitches
Tasha Whitney and Hornsby that is our
top 10 that I put together my
six-year-old son again he doesn't care
about to your list he doesn't care what
everyone else online thinks we just
scrolled through looked at the picture
on the animal crossing new horizons app
and he told me which ones he liked the
best and then we narrowed it down from
there all right so we are here in our
first island let's go and take a look
and see who we got here this is our
first one guys okay but basically we had
someone move out so Lionel moved out so
Lionel moved out so Lionel move down
move down what why not just moved out I
how is this even possible we're off to
just an incredible start ladies and
gentlemen
Lionel is the villager who moved out you
didn't expect to meet someone like me no
no Lionel I didn't you you literally
like just left you were supposed to be
going on to your other town by now the
name's Lionel you don't even remember me
bro all right so back to our island do
we go Wilbur get me out of here dude
first nook miles ticket I'm ready to go
home if you're new here guys welcome to
the stream you're watching retro records
are live we do this thing every Monday
Wednesday and Friday like to start home
9:00 Eastern but it's so hard to get the
kids in bed on time during the summer so
hey here we are at 10 1005 Eastern all
right we are two down and docked at the
Target Island Delta Oscar Delta Oscar is
go are to be out of here oh okay it's
not one of our top ten but I'll go and
check out talk to this bill
see who it is anyway they have kind of a
frowny face one of the cats Tom hello
there Tom I don't think we could have
two Tom's on the island you know we've
already got Tom Nook right your retro
from retro land but wasn't expecting a
meet-and-greet on this tour but then
again I ain't sure what I expected to
find here all right Tom peace out nice
to see you need yes pull out the pole
vault oh now this is a cool island right
here I gotta say who's here
alright they're up there by the fire oh
it's one of the Tigers I gotta say I
love his design that is a pretty cool
design I feel like he'd be fun to hang
around see what kind of personalities
got Leonardo are you here for the
survival training - my name is Leonardo
what's yours
let me know if you need help lifting a
tree or something
all right we already have enough jocks
on our island this is Island number four
guys another spiral oh it's a little
pink oh my goodness a pink mouse with is
that red eyes oh no just like a red
underneath the eyes think it supposed to
be like cheeks candy from another Island
- retroland wow that's a big trip just
to come hang out with me on this sweet
little island let's not get to know each
other sorry candy you do seem like fun I
gotta say you seem like a lot of fun
candy but you know what we're not in our
top ten my apologies we're moving on is
it the same dude it's the same dude why
why is that a thing why
please no duplicates please no
duplicates please just be someone new at
least at least be someone new okay it is
someone new oh it's one of the ducks I
think this might be is that bill
oh it's Admiral not a duck okay
I like the eyebrow I'm a mite fuzzy on
that part aye-aye
Admiral it's been fun my friend glad you
weren't a duplicate glad you weren't
another teleporting villager although I
guess I guess to be fair technically if
I have enough time to fly back home and
then fly to another Island they they
have the same amount of time right
[Music]
ketchup though Raymond let's see who are
my sons top three Octavian Octavian is
his number one choice no not the fishing
rod dude we've gotten this spiral island
several times already
Hyper wow I didn't expect to see anybody
on this island nice to meet you I'm
Piper Piper is peppy very peppy maybe
you know them their name is retro why
yes I do
I do know retro actually a pair of
celebrities ah okay your celebrity
gotcha gotcha well nice chatting we'll
see you later though
it's been a good week so far if you guys
haven't heard they actually changed up
the spawn rate of how the new or how the
NPCs appear so like kicks and flick and
CJ all those people like that so I've
had a good week so far I've already
gotten CJ and I've already gotten flick
and then this Saturday is actually a
fishing tourney so we'll get ccj again
for sure on Saturday so I need to do a
lot of fishing beforehand all right who
do we got here oh that duck looks so
cool not the duck we were looking for
looking for ketchup but I want to see
who this is Molly hello Molly
Oh Molly seems so nice a chance to make
new friends she's so sweet and nice
Molly let's talk to her again change of
scenery is change try that again this
change of scenery has given me a new
perspective on life back on my island I
like it well enough but no we don't want
to remove - yeah you do you got a nice
home you're a very nice person Molly it
was nice chatting with you hope you have
a great trip we're gonna head back
there's another duck that we are looking
for
alright so number eight guys Island
number eight oh my goodness we got a big
huge chicken over here and the spiral
Island yet again look at this dude man
okay he looks cool goose what kind of
voice with goose have hey they're
awesome to meet you know I think he'd be
like hi there also to meet you my name
is goose what about you where you from
retro a you're from retro Lane
cool name from a strong sound in place
so have you ever gone on a solo kayak
tour that suddenly turned into a super
exciting Survival tour oh yeah this is
totally his voice cuz I have and it's so
much fun out here but K oh dude okay
he's cool he's cool but not in our top
ten not one of the villagers we're
looking for okay we are two down no
we're not two down we're I get what
you're saying
Wilbur I get it but do we have here
we're gonna need the ladder oh my gosh
is that him
holy cow guys this is crazy man my son
is going to flip tomorrow I can't
believe this Octavian was my son's
number one choice his number one choice
he is gonna be so pumped about this
tomorrow so if you guys have never seen
my son did a he helps me out with a
pretty awesome video let me put a link
to it here we went through today and
looked at all 391 villagers and I told
him I was like the reason we need to
pick 10 is because it's very unlikely
that I get art one of our top choices
very very unlikely
and I only had 12 miles tickets I was
assuming I was gonna need to buy like 50
and I gotta say like his design is
pretty cool like just the fact that he's
an octopus in general I mean look at
that man that is awesome
all right it's good to step away and
look at things from a distance sometimes
like I'm looking back and wondering if
maybe it's time for me to make some kind
of change
shake stuff up oh yeah Octavian I agree
dude
I agree want to come to my Island yeah
dude I'm asking ya I'm asking you
Octavian I'm asking you do you accept
please don't make me play a game or
something it's a great island you it's
fantastic oh yeah Tom local he'll take
care of it Octavian I'll let my son go
back and watch this tomorrow I need I'm
just gonna start it from the beginning
and say you just need to watch this you
just you just got to watch guess I will
be calling that place home much longer
will I know you will not Octavian let's
go